from crashing a political conference to
kidnapping a TV star there's nothing
that's off limits for Sasha Baron Cohen
and
all right
one of the most iconic moments in the
first Borat movie is probably already
burned into your mind for how perfectly
it captured American culture in the mid
odds in this scene Borat somehow manages
to get a real Rodeo to agree to him
singing the National Anthem before a
show this was during a difficult time in
American history the war in Iraq was at
its peak and then President George W
Bush was a very controversial figure in
political discourse since this scene
took place at a rodeo in Virginia it
should come as no surprise that borat's
audience was definitely leaning
conservative this moment is incredible
for a number of reasons dressed in an
over-the-top patriotic Ensemble Borat
gets the audience wild up by declaring
his enthusiastic support for what he
calls the United States war of Terror
you should drink the blood of every
single man woman and child of Iraq
of course things go truly off the rails
when Borat decides to change the words
to The Star-Spangled Banner to say that
every country that isn't Kazakhstan is
run by little girls the crowd was so
enraged that Sasha Baron Cohen had to be
escorted out of the venue for his own
safety a scene that didn't end up
included in the final film borat's Rodeo
stunt is a perfect example of how Baron
Cohen is willing to put himself in real
danger just to get a reaction
in the sequel to Borat called Borat
subsequent movie film Sasha Baron Cohen
makes an effort to comment directly on
contemporary social and political issues
following the 2016 election Borat ends
up in a number of situations that
reflect on the rise in discrimination
and racism in American culture one
interaction that stands out in the
sequel is when Borat and his daughter
tutar played by Maria bakalova go
shopping for a cage that she must live
in Baron Cohen's intention for the scene
was likely to comment on the ongoing
discrimination against immigrants as the
United States government was keeping
undocumented immigrants in cages despite
the bizarre scenario the store owner
doesn't seem to mind that Borat is
intending to keep his daughter in a cage
instead going along with the whole
ordeal at one point in the sales process
Borat even brings up Donald Trump's
immigration policy which seems to get a
positive reaction but I hear McDonald
Trump yes
it's a perfect example of Baron Cohen's
method of getting people to say exactly
what they're thinking
yet another hilarious scene in the
original Borat comes when Borat learns
how to drive learning to drive is an
essential rite of passage for many
American youths which is why it was a
perfect choice by Sasha Baron Cohen to
put Borat in such a situation paired up
with instructor Michael snitzka Borat
completely fails to comprehend the
nuances of driving while pushing his
teacher's buttons in the process
starting out with an awkward kiss on the
cheek borat's time in the driver's seat
makes for an unforgettably
cringe-inducing sequence once their
conversation devolves into a discussion
about consent and women's rights things
get wild in true Borat fashion the woman
has a right to choose who she has sex
with what how about that there must be
consent
unlike many of the strangers Borat meets
who aren't afraid to express offensive
beliefs his driving instructor tries to
guide him towards doing the right thing
I like you do you like me I do like you
you are my friend you're a nice young
man and I am your friend
as far as men on the street comedy goes
it's hard to beat the subway sequence
near the beginning of the first Borat
film borat's encounters with the
denizens of New York City are simply
hilarious regardless of the context of
who Borat is or where he is from Sasha
Baron Cohen seems to enjoy putting
himself in cringe-worthy situations so
his actions on the subway in this scene
make for an excellent introduction to
borat's time in America First Borat
attempts to kiss several innocent
bystanders taking public transit as a
way of introducing himself this goes
rather poorly of course if that wasn't
enough Borat accidentally lets loose a
live chicken within the crowded subway
car to cause the maximum amount of chaos
only in New York
one highlight of Borat subsequent movie
film is without a doubt the risky prank
pulled during former vice president Mike
Pence's speech at the conservative
political action conference the
conference also known as CPAC has become
an essential yearly event for the
Republican Party Sasha Baron Cohen has
never hidden his left-wing sensibilities
so his desire to cause chaos at CPAC
shouldn't come as a surprise to fans in
the context of the movie Borat
desperately wants to give away his
daughter as a gift to president Donald
Trump at the behest of the president of
Kazakhstan who respects Trump's approach
to governance and wants to be a part of
the club since Borat cannot approach the
sitting U.S president he settles for
giving away his daughter to Pence
instead during his CPAC speech Borat
dresses up as Donald Trump and
infiltrates the event but he causes a
ridiculous Ruckus when he starts yelling
at Pence on stage
I brought the girl for you
Baron Cohen is openly not a fan of trump
as he has expressed on Twitter so
dressing up as him through his Borat
character uses several layers of irony
to criticize the Republican Party
Sasha Baron Cohen doesn't need to rely
on raunchy or political humor to get a
laugh in the original 2006 Borat one of
the funniest moments is a G-rated gag
that anyone who's read Dr Seuss can
appreciate in one very brief scene Borat
visits the Exotic Wildlife dealers at
Munch ranch when presented with a
certain slow-moving reptile the
journalist doesn't seem to recognize the
creature what type of dog is this this
is a tortoise the patience of the two
employees featured in this scene is
truly quite admirable is this a cat in a
hat no it's a tortoise and a shell yes
this scene has become a favorite among
Borat fans for its simple premise and
hysterical delivery
borat's relationship with his daughter
tutar is the heart and soul of borat's
subsequent movie film with a surprising
amount of character growth for the
titular reporter while he is constantly
putting his loving daughter into
troubling situations Borat and tutar
grow closer and closer with each absurd
encounter when Borat brings tutar to a
southern debutant ball in Disguise he
goes in with the intention of presenting
her as a proper young lady as you can
imagine this doesn't sit well with the
other guests what unfolds is a standout
moment in the film in which Borat and
tutar under the fake names Sandra
Jessica Parker Drummond and Professor
Philip drumon III do what they claim is
a traditional Kazakh fertility dance the
dance involves showing a room full of
Stuffy Southern Aristocrats tutar's
blood-stained underwear which they
respond to by awkwardly clapping this
mockery of high society in the south is
genuinely hilarious and the dance itself
is surprisingly well choreographed and
executed by the two stars the running
joke at the heart of Borat is the
journalist's obsession with Baywatch
actress Pamela Anderson after seeing her
on television Borat falls deeply in love
with her and throughout his hijinks he
continues to bring up his desire to find
her and make her his wife
Having learned the many lessons from us
and day
I will now teach America how to have a
wedding kazaki style
this plot line finally ends with the
failed kidnapping attempt by Borat who
tries to put a traditional marriage sack
over Anderson's head while this may
sound horrifying it turns out that
Pamela Anderson was in on the joke all
along according to the Daily Beast Sasha
Baron Cohen made sure to get Anderson's
approval ahead of time the comedian told
the outlet the first time we did it at a
book signing and I grabbed her over my
shoulder and ran out with her and no one
did anything I was like what kind of
fans are these so we did it again and
they started running after me however
there were definitely some unintended
consequences to Anderson's role in Borat
Baron Cohen explained that Anderson's
then husband Kid Rock ended up divorcing
her over the entire thing he elaborated
I thought it was a joke but then a few
weeks later they got divorced and they
put as a reason for divorce Borat
the Borat subsequent movie film scene
that got the most press attention after
release was centered around former New
York city mayor Rudy Giuliani in keeping
with Sasha Baron Cohen's desire to mess
with Republican political figures he and
his team came up with the idea to
disguise Maria bakalova as a
conservative journalist who attempts to
seduce Giuliani on camera in the context
of the story this is actually a low
point for Borat and tutar Borat has had
a change of heart about his daughter
after realizing how much he actually
loves her meanwhile tutar has decided to
proceed with the seduction plan in order
to win his approval what unfolds is a
shockingly disturbing scene in which
Giuliani seems to accept the seduction
attempt despite the fact that he was
under the impression that tutar is
underage this was a seemingly genuine
act on giuliani's part as he had no idea
he was in a Borat film until it was too
late his unacceptable Behavior became
the center of the political news cycle
for some time
[Music]